bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti avesse
un figlio sono fa vj oggi siamo suisse
che pende presen sempre più figo di 20
ragazzi sarebbe il sequel di the
steering the diamond che avevo fatto
tipo una settimana fa più o meno la
buongiorno mi chiamo tanto segno questi
capelli basette troppo sexy zio ancora
ragazzi non devo fare lo scarta joe dei
pacchi in diretta dalla cella
praticamente hanno una torcia volete
dirmi che dentro una [ __ ] torta ci
sono teste stronza anche anche un
bazooka ragazzi prima inter sarebbe il
sequel di siringhe da iamm anche dopo
aver rubato il diamante sto tizio è
stato messo in galera giustamente quindi
ago fuggire di gala ragazzi sarà
fantastico anche se non non ho ben
capito come fa entrare tutta sta merda
in una torta però vabbè prendo bazooka
che figo che posso sfondare le forze
così ragazzi no manca ho mancato la
cella di brutto ho appena assistito alla
cosa più epica della vita usiamo del
drill dai facciamo questo perché non è
questa funziona per forza che non può
non funzionare
parimenti ragazzi devo riuscire a
fuggire di prigione in teoria sarebbe
questo obiettivo in chiave mi stavo
meglio dovevo prima però opacità ator
che cazzo è uno file cos'è sta roba
puoi camminare attraverso praticamente
posso passare attraverso i muri costa
roba mia
ok forse forse non era così utile nuova
vena figata legale cioè che sono andato
sotto terra praticamente fanta ho perso
stava andando nel centro della terra
ragazzi quanta quindi non è la soluzione
giusta perfetto chi l'avrebbe mai detto
che sarebbe stato sbagliato adesso siamo
un piede di porco che è meglio che
almeno a faccio solid snake nei condotti
meraviglioso giorno sentite ecco
perfetto ma perché mi devo ritrovare in
queste situazioni di merda ogni volta
cazzo
non lo dico che devo cliccare perfetti
sono morto grandioso dovevo cliccare sul
sulle frecce perfetto
adesso siamo mancati ma si può mancato
il tasto ma si può essere più deficienti
sono talmente monco che manco i tasti
fantastico ok stavolta lo spiccato
perfetto ce l'ho fatta devo ancora
schiva ma quanto è il mio questo tizio
riga devo andare in mezzo a muri mezza
muro io ovviamente sono andato contro il
muro ma ci mancherebbe si fa essere fide
vincenti nel cervello secondo me no ecco
forse no forse sì
devo riuscire niente di ciò perché
succede a noi sbatto fantasticando di
sotto adesso non perché sono faccio
confusione fosse andato di sottoprefetto
chiamato a no sono molto uguale sono
morto
e allora che cazzo serve renzo iphone
d'asta mi sa che dovrà ripartire
all'inizio lega perché è sbagliata
quella via delle forti temi
teletrasporto fuori ragazzi è l'unica
perché se non ce l'ho fatta
ce l'ho fatta non è possibile no energy
drink va bene questo ragazzo in energy
drink anche se non è ma che cazzo ho
bevuto ragazzo si è fermato il tempo
cioè ho bevuto un coso si è fermato il
tè o che è il fantastico 9 ragazzi bebè
re energy drink fa questo effetto
effettivamente meraviglioso sono
talmente ma perché ma per ma perché il
gioco non può avere meno senso dico
giusto ma rubiamo le brioche dagli
agenti hanno una ciambella che prefetto
non regga veramente sto gioco e la è la
cosa più no sense del ma non può far
male che sto tornando normale ma non
sono morto perfetto e non è servito a un
cazzo di niente ho camminato mezz'ora in
mezzo alla gente poi son morto giusto 9
dic era la lima cioè una lima era era la
soluzione alla fine la finestra limiamo
la finestra vino fresco dove cazzo mi
butto nel nel vuoto
in fanno sapere ma sono un deficiente
anch'io però dobbiamo andare sul sulla
porta mi sa che la porta giusta dai
provato di tutto tipo energy drink tele
porter di tutto bazooka e poi alla fine
era una lima adesso è anche un'arma
potresti bastona notte grazie va bene lo
sapevo non lo sapevo ragazzi ecco l'ho
preso l'opera ed shot no e va beh ma
allora siete bastardino matrix devo
combattere contro un miliardo di persone
adesso sono morti tutti possa andare
avanti inter cazzo no non sono i ragazzi
non sono io
grandissimo sono riuscito a mettermi in
salvo in una stanza bruttissima cintura
di granate o sedia
io vado con la cintura di granate mi
sembra più seria sì però ragazzi non è
possibile può essere più [ __ ]
dice no abbiate pazienza allora c'era la
soluzione a sinistra sinistra motoria
dovrei passare sopra quei tizi a
sinistra cioè interni e bellissimo sto
gioco perché ci sono un miliardo di cose
che puoi fare per il 99 per cento sono
stronzate quindi non so se ha scelto
quella giusta
qualcosa mi vinse rin occhio è lo stato
doveva andare ovviamente se c'è un 50
per cento becco sempre con lo sbagliato
ci mancherebbe destra perfetto a sono sì
ok
stavolta ce lo fa stavolta ce l'ho fatta
non so come ma ce l'ho fatta
abbiamo jeff beck paracadute ero io
direi di fare paracadute dai che mi
sembra la meno tragica di tutte anche se
madonna che stile china buttarti zio non
era un parecchio sul che cosa cazzo una
padella non era un paracadute fantastico
tutte le cose che potranno ovviamente
non era un paracadute facciamola rope va
a è un rampino giusto alla ragazza
troppo garanti il no
non avevo i guanti quindi son caduto
fantastico quindi se non va
sono vivo sono cloni ok perfetto ma
porca [ __ ] jack perché non penso siano
le ventose quindi almeno oggetto non era
al jazz air al jazz
non era il jetpack perché sono ritornato
nella cella dove era partito niente gare
possono perché non siano l'evento sei
rimasto questo praticamente chiuso le
ventose veramente cioè erano le erano
l'evento 0 siamo seri
rapp davvero ho vinto ho vinto ho vinto
a caso ma giustamente ci mancherebbe che
siano delle ventose di merda a farmi
scappare giusto rai a different assi che
c'è un altro file ragazzi provo un altro
finale perché rega non è possibile sarò
di nuovo in culo che casa ma matrix a
caso magari è diventato che sa qualcosa
ragazze c'è uno scontro a fuoco di
quelli pesanti devo affrontare sto tizio
baffuto ai baffi sotto gli occhi tra
l'altro che io sono pronto alla mezz'ora
09 a [ __ ] porca tra l'altro che succede
ora forse perché prima non avevo proprio
cliccata ho mancato di nuovo il tasto
quindi sono andato a sbattere fantastico
ok adesso sono pronto e che adesso sono
pronto
[Musica]
morirà si si oh mio dio
ok allora cosa sta succedento mio di
matrix all improvviso adesso fa il frigo
i temi se vi sembra normale una cosa c'è
sei uscita sei uscito così ma stai
scherzando
l'ho fatto naufragare non ci posso non è
possibile c'è ma vi rendete conto della
delle stronzate dire basta ea sue è
veramente assurdo comunque ragazzi è
stato è stato un bello giocare a
sappiamo veramente nonché ragazzi ho
scoperto adesso politche è finita in
prigione perché ha tentato di rapinare
una banca ed era l'episodio prima che
non l'ho fatto ho fatto questo
ovviamente ho fatto quello dopo devo
fare prima quello della rapina nella
banca e poi dopo quello la prigione
fantastico tutti ragazzi spero che il
video vi sia piaciuto nel prossimo
episodio se vi è piaciuto faccio anche
quello prima che non ho fatto molti
ragazzi servito mi è piaciuto ma se
rilasciato un commento mi piace anche a
pagare facebook che come lo divido tra
tra descrizione se non se volessi di
scappini ci vediamo al prossimo video
belle ragazze